you ever sat next to this every other
second in the theater every time an
actor shows up on screen you ever have
someone point them out all the time ever
sat next to someone who just keeps
repeating every single line from the
movie they're just so excited and
there's so enthused about it they have
to remember every [ __ ] thing in the
moment that's what I said next to and
that was Jerry they owe the expendables
32 bit do so this is the book the
mentally challenged oh dude that is so
[ __ ] up I did not just say that now
admit does this film have flaws oh yeah
it is yeah it's pretty evident but of
course it's going to it's the [ __ ]
Expendables like they ever give a [ __ ] I
was really let down by the first
Expendables the second one was like it's
an improvement but it's looked could be
a lot better this third one though oh
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] about the rating
systems that are going out there for
this one I thought it was a blast and
even the parts where it's just like dad
filmmaking adds to the fun I didn't get
this way about the first two but this
time around I was like I really like
seeing these old action stars on screen
together it's pretty [ __ ] cool I mean
seeing Arnold Schwarzenegger just
kicking ass again is always awesome I
support the RT come back despite him
impregnating some woman out of wedlock I
mean we all make mistakes I have three
pregnant woman in my life and four
children okay well three one of them's
black obviously not mine I forgave Arnie
for his you know personal life which I
have nothing to do with and it doesn't
[ __ ] matter what I think about it but
my one problem with the character was it
sort of felt like his role at a skate
plan where he's like the assistant
helper boy to Sylvester Stallone I
didn't really see that dynamic in the
first two so this one was kind of weird
but still it's cool team on screen again
and even had it Harrison Ford is that to
the cast of filming for Bruce Willis
it's a different character but he's
obviously there to replace Bruce Willis
who was an [ __ ] by the way [ __ ] you
Bruce Willis you hear you're a douchebag
in real life i'll still watch her movies
but [ __ ] you Harrison Ford at least
seems like he's enjoying himself bruce
watson like getting your [ __ ] Harrison
Ford he's obviously having a good
I'm making this money and cashing in on
that awesome pager although the first
time he shows up I thought he had
Parkinson's disease which is not a
laughing matter it is only funny when
you were alone with friends cracking
jokes and they added Wesley Snipes to
the cast honestly I did not miss blade
that much I don't really give a [ __ ]
about Wesley Snipes being in this film
but he was like pretty [ __ ] enjoyable
though man he was having a good time
first half hour this movies like the
Wesley Snipes show and it's [ __ ]
awesome I like having him be a part of
this cast he fits perfectly like Terry
Crews you know he's a black guy and he's
really [ __ ] cool and all but we
needed an old black action star and
Denzel Washington still has too much
respect to be a part of this and one of
the greatest things to happen to the
expendable franchise Antonio been days
this dude is the definition of eccentric
now you're either gonna love him or
you're gonna [ __ ] hate his guts I can
totally see why if you thought he was
annoying but in my personal opinion he
was a hoot get me cracking up like every
time he was on screen I found myself
enjoying myself that was not a
masturbation joke but it could have been
quite a different flavor to the cast all
everyone else you know pretty much the
same she's like wacky and really out
there and I [ __ ] loved him he was
like a little boy I don't have a thing
for little boys I mean he's spirit was
like a little boy can I just clear up
that I I don't have any association with
any little boys I don't I don't babysit
I don't I don't look at them I hate them
honestly I want nothing to do with them
unless you're a little boy and thanks
for subscribing but my favorite
performer without a doubt is one of my
favorite actors of all time that's right
I'm sane and I've been saying it for
years Mel [ __ ] gives it this guy
proves again and again that he is the
[ __ ] he was the villain in machete kills
and he was like one of a few good things
about it and he's the best actor in this
film by far he makes one hell of a
villain and he proves again why he's the
[ __ ] look I don't know Gibson's kind of
had a fucked-up personal life okay
something about Jews and being his
ex-girlfriend whatever we move on okay
like he doesn't speak much in like the
first 40 minutes of this film but they
eventually get to this monologue that he
delivers the Stallone and it is such
a good Malik that was one of the but
that's probably the best part of this
movie it's like the one time where it
feels like this is a real film now it
was great he he's just oh [ __ ] I want
him to make a comeback so bad now if
you're watching this I love you and
Bruce Willis if you're watching this you
can go [ __ ] yourself I don't remember
with the title of die hard 5 is that
movie sucked sort of red too so as your
next [ __ ] phone was gonna come out I
bet no sin city to looks awesome
something else that I think might you
know might not flat too well with some
audience members they focus a lot and
like for alia solid 45 minutes mainly on
the new Expendables they're good they're
not bad but they're just not as you pay
to go watch them basically I mean
they're a good cat shirt but they're not
really that distinguished too much I
mean they got this one like computer
hacker guy who was really cool but
everyone else is just another action
hero we can kick asses equally as the
old Expendables but when the two come
together they're pretty [ __ ] sweet
action team man and I even thought the
action improved too don't let the pg-13
rating to tear you from this film that's
the first time i will use the word
two-tier I wonder if I used it properly
the body count and violence is still
ridiculously high I mean there's just a
lack of blood but it's still pretty
[ __ ] violent and it definitely
features some of the best action
sequences of the franchise some of the
best shots of the franchise I mean a lot
of it is just ridiculous and the more
ridiculous it is the better the film
it's because you just want it to be
ridiculous ma'am like the first toy I
were missing a genuine sense of fun and
I thought these guys were really having
a fun time being together Jerry said it
best he said it was like the movie grown
ups but with old action stars just a
bunch of people coming together you want
to see hang out and kick some ass
murdering looks like so much fun after
watching this one I want to murder a
bunch of people yeah I had a fun time it
was entertaining so yeah check this [ __ ]
out let me get straight to the point
here oh and all i gotta say the
expendables 3 got it cheering erectile
dysfunction right
alright guys i'm checking out my review
for the expendables 3 why don't you go
ahead scroll that out soon box comment
box my dad below and tell me who would
you like to see added to the expendables
cast last not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews or
videos is out going to clearance but
about my dick to subscribe that's right
the dick let me say something about this
little old action hero he has been with
many expendable the Jardins mainly
because I'm stds